EU ministers for transport will seek a  general approach on a proposal giving  new tasks to the European railway agency  and streamlining its processes the  proposed regulation is part of the  fourth railway package published by the  European Commission its aim is to remove  barriers hampering the creation of a  single European railway area ministers  are also expected to adopt their  position on a proposal to develop a  coordinated EU approach to research and  innovation in the rail sector the idea  is to set up a public-private  partnership shift to rail to support the  development of better rail services in  Europe and boost the sector's  competitiveness finally there'll be a  policy debate on competitive and  resource-efficient urban mobility